wie viel energie haben wir als land als
gesellschaft für solidarität
wir können auch einmal schweren für ihn
schreien sind wir bereit das aus
mitgefühl mitleid wird bereit energie
importe aus russland komplett zu stoppen
so fort ich würde mich dagegen
aussprechen weil wir damit den sozialen
frieden in der republik gefährden
zwischen moral und realpolitik zieht die
bundesregierung diese woche ihre
schmerzgrenze der solidarität man würde
gerne putin die rote sanktions karte
zeigen aber es reicht nur für die gelbe
kein komplett embargo wenn wohlstand und
wirtschaft gefährdet sind
in deutschland gesichert werden und
unsere industrie eben auch
wirtschaft insgesamt weiterhin
erfolgreich ist so das sind die dinge
die die für uns jetzt hier prioritär sei
prioritär ein hauch von germany first
angesichts schon jetzt explodierender
energiepreise
haushaltsenergie und kraftstoffe waren
schon im februar 22 5 prozent teurer als
im vorjahr der zehnte märz war der
bisher teuerste tag aller zeiten an den
zapfsäulen mit zwei euro 20 für benzin
und zwei euro 32 für die
100 liter heizöl kosten aktuell 185 euro
etwa doppelt so viel wie vor dem krieg
in der ukraine
die energiefrage wird zur sozialen frage
der zeit die bundesregierung ist
gefordert zu handeln denn gerade
diejenigen mit geringen einkommen sind
in dieser situation in besonderer weise
diejenigen die nicht über den monat
kommen die ampel hatte vor dem krieg
entlastungen bei energiepreisen auf den
weg gebracht die nun zu verpuffen drohen
weitere maßnahmen etwa ein energie geld
werden diskutiert andere die nichts
kosten wirken wie ein tempolimit von der
fdp blockiert dabei ist es extrem teuer
sich vom lieferanten putin zu lösen beim
öl vor allem aber beim gas die
abhängigkeit die wir in der tat von
importen aus russland haben die ist
immens groß über 55 grad 55 prozent gas
kommt aus russland wir haben auch mit
party von kohle wärmen portal
dass das ist nicht sind fehler die in
der vergangenheit liegen hausgemachte
fiel nicht nur die sozialdemokratischen
schröder erben auch die cdu steht vor
den trümmern ihrer energiepolitik der
letzten 16 jahren seit beginn ihrer
kanzlerschaft hatte angela merkel
warnungen beiseite gewischt ist es ihnen
unheimlich so stark von einem partner
abhängig zu sein von russland ich würde
da auch jetzt nicht kassandrarufe
ausstoßen wir setzen auf einen
zuverlässigen lieferanten russland die
russische seite hatte noch mal gesagt
sie will energie nicht als waffe
einsetzten verheerende fehleinschätzung
merkel hat deutschland abhängig und
verwundbare hinterlassen sowie putin es
haben wollte aus den worten mit denen
die aktuelle außenministerin nun ein
energie embargo ablehnt spricht die
ganze ohnmacht
dass ihr krankenhäuser nicht mehr
wirklich am laufen halten können es sind
tage düstere szenarien und abwägungen wo
endet solidarität und beginnt und
zumutbarkeit für cdu-wahlkämpfer tobias
hans lässt sich das genau beziffern bei
zwei euro 12 für diesel hat er gut
getarnt sich an diesen gestiegenen
energiekosten und deswegen muss eine
preisblase her das trifft jetzt wird nur
geringverdiener sondern dass dort
wirklich die vielen fleißigen leute
gedanken müssen während hans wegen hoher
energiepreise die hutschnur reist rufen
ausgerechnet cdu parteifreunde zum
import stopp für öl und gas auffordern
vom bürger verzicht und für den gürtel
enger schnallen müssen für einige monate
mit generell russland die einnahmen zu
verringern in einem ersten schritt in
einem europäischen gesamt konzert könnte
etwa nord stream 1 abgeschaltet werden
ein vorstoß getragen von
oppositionsführer märz der in der
wirtschaft manchen vergrätzt herr merz
hat den stopp der nordstream 1
lieferungen ins spiel gebracht das wäre
für die deutsche wirtschaft ein sehr
sehr starker schlag es würde sofort
auswirkungen auf lieferketten auf
produktionsprozesse auch haben von daher
ist das ein vorschlag der sicherlich
nicht von der deutschen wirtschaft auch
mitgetragen wird deutschland hat sich
über jahre fahrlässig abhängig gemacht
von russischem stoff und muss nun auf
entzug es könnte für manche ein kalter
werden